[Music]
a new precedent for bolivia
after a year filled with unrest and
violence luis cersei
was sworn in on sunday surrounded by
members of the country's indigenous
communities and foreign representatives
arses says he wants to govern an
inclusive bolivia
we want a government for everyone with
no discrimination we will seek
unity to live in peace in this road
democracy is crucial
so we can get people's votes free and
fair elections
for everyone
accusations of fraud in the elections
last year
ended with the resignation of bolivia's
first indigenous leader evo morales
evo morales is returning to bolivia on
monday after being in exile here in
argentina for
almost a year it's not clear yet which
role if any he's going to play
in the new government of luis sarseh who
will have to show he is in charge
and not a puppet of the still popular
and influential modalis
outgoing interim president janinas who
took office after morale's resignation
last year
was not present at the ceremony but
arsene
made clear his view of her leadership
the two objectives of the de facto
government were to pacify and call for
elections
they did not fulfill them instead they
began persecuting and kill political
opponents
during the inauguration the president
called for a minute of silence for those
killed during the protest last year
bolivia is deeply divided between poor
and rural sectors in the highlands
and the richer lowlands indigenous
communities play a crucial role
in the new administration of louis
saracen
we are mayans guarani mapuches we are
aimara and quechuas
we are people of the culture of life
that sparked our wise rebellion
now there is a new dawn in our history
where empathy for others and collective
good replace individualism
luis cersei will rule a divided country
that is struggling with the impact of
covet 19.
he was economy minister while morales
was in office and responsible for the
economic growth that empowered
millions of people in the country but
analysts say the situation
is different now when the mass party was
in power in the past
there was an economic boom that gave
them money to help the population
latin america and bolivia are in crisis
bolivia has a 13
deficit so it's not going to be easy and
there are other problems like
concerns over racism and regional
rivalries have re-emerged in the past
year
small protests have been on the rise in
recent days
but arses presidency is viewed as a
guarantee for bolivia's indigenous
majority
that they won't be left behind perez